hello everybody and welcome to episode
six of my buying and selling in Pay
to-play series uh where we're going to
go from 0o to 100 Mil using the grand
exchange only and we're going to be
renewing the bond only with the money we
earn from flipping as opposed to paying
for it with real
money title starting to become a bit of
a mouthful but yeah so anyway thank you
for everyone who left a comment on the
last video I got loads of comments it's
actually going to be uh decent amount of
people in the draw for the 1.4 mil I'm
going start stop taking names today and
uh we're going to release the winner
with the next video the only reason for
that is because there's a tway delay
kind of one day sometimes on the
subscriber page and obviously I just
want to give the money away to someone
who subscribed to me uh CU you guys have
been supporting me for a while um but
yeah that out of the way we'll jump into
the episode here we're starting about
4.8 mil and we'll get back with the
first item okay so first up here I think
we're going to do the energy potion
again uh you saw briefly on screen um I
bought it for about 485 for the four do
potion in the three do potion was like
385 after doing the calculations the
relative margin is about 40 GP and so we
actually bought it for the high price
there at 3.96 so uh these should not
take very long to buy and uh hopefully
we can make what 80k from
that okay so after checking the
calculation on the prayer potion um 3/4
of the high price was
9561 taking off 9200 or something for
the Buy price gives us about 361 GP
margin on each potion which is really
good
fortunately I don't actually have much
money to buy these PA potions CU they're
rather expensive I think we can only
really get 400 of them but still 400 of
them and about a 360 GP margin uh should
be about 144k so we'll try these and
look they almost all insta bot that's
what I really like about this technique
so we'll come back when these have fully
bought and uh
sold okay so this didn't work as well we
didn't get nearly as many items as we
needed to to make any sort of profit um
but on the pair potions we got 48 GP
margin they dropped down quite
substantially got 400 of them but that's
only like
19k on the energy potions we got like
none we only got 112 of them or
something at about 40 GP margin got us
about 4K so that was pretty unsuccessful
we're going to go try this a couple more
times cuz that was lame okay so first up
is the Rune arrows these were selling
for 5 GP margin pretty consistent again
so we'll just buy the cap out amount 11k
and uh we'll get on to a second
item okay so next up I I think we're
going to try the super defense potion uh
we're just getting the potions bought so
we can check the margin here just got
the foros potion uh so we'll go ahead
and calculate one more time just to make
sure you guys understand what is going
on here so we're taking the four do
potion which is 2946 multiplying it by
75 to get a 3/4 price and then we
subtract either the Buy price or the
sell price at the three dose potion to
get our margin uh in this case we might
just buy it for the high price because
they're close enough and there's still a
pretty decent margin on it either way
okay so we just quickly checked OS budy
just for the how many they sell every
day just to check it and I think we're
going to buy it for the high price cuz
it still had 180 GP margin per potion
which is still really nice really um so
like 180 GP times I mean almost 2,000
that we can get we'll get probably two
or 300K from this um so yeah we got
these two items I think yeah look we
already bought a couple so we'll check
back when we bought and sold them
all all right there we go so I can
already tell this is much more
successful um both the super defense and
the Rune arrows made a ton on so we'll
start with the Rune arrows we actually
manag get a six GP margin on that and we
got just under 11k of them giving us
about 64k in profit the defense potions
we got about 180 GP margin after
calculations and we got 600 of those we
got about 288k from potions which is
awesome that's really good didn't take
that long honestly um yeah let's just go
do this a couple more times
really okay so first up here I think
we're going to do the defense potion
again I had about two two or 300 GP
margin after calculations which is still
really nice we almost made 300K on it
last time so we're going to try it again
see if it was just a fluke or not um so
we'll go buy it for about 1970 and we'll
get 2K and yeah get one more item
going okay so uh next up here the energy
potion is looking pretty good uh we'll
do the calculation again uh so 582 *
75 and I think we're just going to go
for the high price probably this time so
minus 400 um times 2,000 we get so
that's 73k and it'll probably only cost
it'll probably cost us about Mill to get
the items maybe a bit
less okay so we're gonna go ahead and
buy a couple thousand of these we'll go
for the high price just because we kind
of like to buy them quicker let's see
how many bought oh yeah so the insta bot
all of them bought so that's basically
70k in the bag already uh that's what I
kind of like about buying it for the
high price it's a lot more quick you get
a lot more of these done in a shorter
amount of time um so yeah again we're
just going to come down here decant them
from
Bob decant so we have 50 00 now and
we'll run back and sell them and we'll
probably get about 30 GP profit on each
one once again this is worked
exceedingly well um start with the
energy potions cuz I was a lesser of
them we got about 36 GP margin on those
and we got the full 2,000 uh so that's
about 73k from the energy potions you
can see right there the defense potions
however we got 263 GP margin about 1,700
of those that's 462k you can kind of see
right there right beside each other over
4 K and that was only about two to 3 mil
invested which is awesome return so I'm
not sure if we're going to keep doing
this the entire episode but if it's
still working this way probably going to
so yeah we'll be back with a couple
items okay so to mix things up a little
bit well not really we're going to do
the attack potion uh it had a pretty
decent margin on it I think about 100 GP
um the adjusted price was 743 minus
678 uh which is going to be about okay
65 GP margin on it but I think that was
the high price so we've already bought
some of the potions so we'll get another
item on the go while we're buying
these okay so next upep I think we might
try the super anti poison so again going
to take the high price times it by 75
messed that up a little bit there um
which is going to give us the adjusted
price so1 1575 and we can take either
the Buy price or the sell price I'm not
really it's a pretty hefty difference so
I think we might go for the the lower
price this time okay so yeah I think
we're going to go for the lower price
this time it was 1210 and we'll go buy
2K of those should get a decent profit
although I think these buy fairly slowly
but still for each one we buy we're
going to get like two or 300
GP okay so I think lastly here we tried
a couple more potions but they seem to
have been already competed for a little
bit today so we'll do the Rune arrows
again has a 6 GP margin on it bought
them for 139 sold them for 133 uh so
that's always nice and we will check
back when these are
done okay so we've sold most things here
uh we're still selling off the super
anti poisons but we'll do a little quick
update um the super attacks have all
sold for 83 GP margin uh given us about
166k in profit uh the Rune arrows have
all sold for actually a 7 GP margin we
got 11k of those that's 77k in profit
and uh the super anti poisons are still
selling but are still sorry still buying
um but I think we're probably going to
take them out and de can't them right
now but uh we will just sell off all the
crap in our inventory first and we'll
get to
that okay so to start off here just
going to start by decanting the super
anti poisons I'm not going to wait to
buy any more of those cuz they were
buying pretty slowly but we actually did
manage to get a fair amount of those I'm
pretty happy I think we're going to get
a good amount of profit from these we'll
probably just calculate it when we sell
them all uh but we'll plop them in here
for let's see here probably 2100 then
and uh that should leave us I think
probably with 300K profit at least cuz
we were getting a decent margin on these
uh so yeah we'll come back uh with a
couple more items
here okay so next next up here we're
going to do the super defense I think
again really been working quite well I
mean we'll just do the calculation with
you again 3,000 * 75 it's
2250 uh if we take off the high price
which we could buy them for we'll get
about 150 GP profit if we take off the
low price we'll get almost 200 so I mean
either way we'll be
getting between 3 and 400k which is
amazing for how cheap the item is really
um so I think what we're going to do is
actually do the high price cuz they do
take a while to buy uh so the high price
being I think
2159 or something s right looks like
we're actually going to go for the low
price here and uh we're I think cuz
we're going to leave this in
overnight okay so we're back and these
both worked incredibly well like we made
I think we made over over M on this flip
alone so like the super defenses we got
354 GP margin on and we got about 1,700
of them which leaves us with 600k in
profit you can see right there the super
defense I mean sorry the super anti-
poisons we got a little bit worse but
still really good we got 357 GP profit
on each one we only got 1,200 of those
only reason why I was worse but we still
got 432k from that in total we probably
got close to 1 mil 50k which is insane
for those items was so safe no
problems awesome technique can't say
anything bad about it really um so let's
continue on
here okay so what we're going to do is
we're going to buy the energy potion and
the plan here was since this is recorded
like a week ago this clip um I was
actually going to be gone three days in
music festival which was awesome I went
to already um but the plan was is I'm
just going to try to buy a bunch of the
items while I'm gone at least I put an
offer in so we're not totally wasting
our time so we put an offer in for 6K I
understand it's way higher than the
buying limit but we were planning be
gone for a couple days um so we will see
if these actually bought or
not okay so we're going to try the super
anti-poison here it has a really good
margin on it it's like 37 75 the problem
comes here when I again I mess up and I
buy it for the high price again so I I
put it in for 2150 when it should have
been like 1,5 or something and I'm like
oh my God they all bought well look at
that and we go back and we look so the
high price was 21105 of the super
antipoison 4 so we bought them for way
more expensive than they're supposed to
be the funny thing is though is I think
we're still going to
profit um just based on the fact that
there's such a big margin item uh we
bought off all the so look we bought
them for
1538 and um the high price is 2100 so we
take that times it by0 75 minus 1538
looks like we're still going to get a 37
GP margin on each item so we should
still get 75k which is insane just shows
you how good this technique is we
totally messed up and we're still going
to profit um so yeah we'll plop them in
these back in I mean in the end this may
have actually been good no no not really
but um I'll be optimistic about it so
hopefully we'll at least break even on
this
item Okay so we've sold mostly
everything here uh we sold off the anti-
poisons and the energy potions forgot to
mention we actually put another offer in
CU I was a little pissed off that we
bought them for so high we put him
another offer in but not many bought
anyway so but uh the anti poisons we
actually did profit on we stole them in
two different chunks little confusing
but we actually did make 60k profit I
had a quick look at it um and the energy
potions we got about 34 GP margin on and
we got about 3,800 giving us about 130k
profit so you can see even though I
totally goofed it out we still made 60k
profit about 200k on that flip in total
so really not too bad so we'll continue
on here I think we're going to start off
just by decanting the super anti poisons
we did manage to get didn't get a whole
lot uh but we'll get we'll sell them
back for maybe 20 30k profit yeah so
we're going to put them in here for
about that price 2055 um we'll put them
in one GP lower cuz these don't sell
very often often and we only 51 of them
to dump and yeah we'll get some actual
items going
here so I think we're going to do the
super attack potion um either way we're
going to make profit if we go for the
low price we're going to make about 70k
if we go for the um sorry if we go for
the high price we'll make about 70k if
we go for the low price I think we're
going to get over 100k uh which is
pretty good especially since it's not a
very expensive item so we'll go buy it
for about 653 and uh we're going to
leave in a good amount of these because
again we're planning on being gone now
is when we're actually leaving so we'll
go ahead put a offer in for a bunch of
items and uh we'll get one more going at
least okay so next up here we're going
to do the energy potion again uh has
about a 30 GP margin if we buy it for
the high price uh which will give us
about 60k and that's it's not a lot but
it's pretty decent for how cheap the
item is really and I've never had a
problem flipping these items I've never
lost money on it so we'll go ahead buy
it for the uh high price here of about
402 or
something not 3gb sorry 403 and we'll go
buy 2,000 of
those okay so last here we're going to
do the antipoison you can see here it
has an insane margin going on here um
821 minus either of those will give us a
massive margin so I think we're actually
going to go for the high price I'm not
really sure if we're going to buy them
any for that low price um but yeah
either way we're getting 300 400 GP
profit in each one really no reason not
to try this I'm feeling like we're not
going to get too many of these bought
but we'll put it in for the high price
and just see how many we can get right
off the bat here so I think the high
price is 554 545 and we'll buy 2,000 the
begin right
away no that's not too surprised with
that one but yeah we'll come back when
uh most stuff has bought and sold and I
think that's where we're going to wrap
up the
episode okay so we're back and we've
sold mostly everything except for the
regular anti poisons um but I think this
where we're going to end the episode
we'll do a quick rundown of the last
bits of money that we made um so to
start off with the super gry poisons we
didn't get a whole lot of them we only
got like 70 of them or something um but
that still left us with a 325 GP margin
giving us 23k on the super anti poisons
the super attacks we got a 59 GP margin
on and we got about 3,800 of those that
got us the most money at about
230k and the regular energy potions we
got 2,000 of them and we got about 38 GP
margin from that which gives us about
73k um so pretty happy with the last PP
there and in total after we sell off all
this crap in our inventory and the but
125k or something left of anti poisons
we have that'll bring us to about 7.5
mil and uh we started the episode at
about 4.7 mil that's about 2.7 mil we
made in this episode which is probably
one of the highest amounts and these are
all from consistent flips we didn't get
Super Lucky really we just did these
over and over again I mean we did kind
of run the potions to the ground
hopefully you guys aren't bored though
because we are making a good amount of
money uh we're ending on day eight so we
still have about half our membership
left which is nice so I'm hoping we get
up to about the 11 12 mil Mark with this
membership and once we hit the 10 mil
Mark we'll start flipping some kind of
more expensive items like maybe the
infinity robes or um some kind of low
tier rare items but uh yeah so thanks
for sticking it out guys one last
question would you guys prefer to have
music in the videos or do you like just
the basic RuneScape music um just let me
know in the comments down below if
you're interested in having some just
some kind of light casual background
music or just the original RuneScape
music okay thanks for watching guys I
will see you guys in episode
[Music]